[Music]
what cliches about LA there aren't that
nice right and one of the things la gets
a really bad rap for all of the vanity
license plates that are out there people
like to brag with their vanity plates
yeah yeah and their here's an example
we've shown before 5k a day which means
this guy either runs 5k a day or earns
5k a day but either way he's a douche
bag
and now now we've repeatedly pointed him
out as an example of a douche bag
television yeah exactly
now I just wanted to say something okay
that's the cliche about LA we're all
driving around with that kind of license
plate there get a load of me license
exactly I might try to buy that it's to
expect all really wanna points too many
letters I wanted to point out that a lot
of very humble people live here in Los
Angeles too and to prove it we went out
and we photographed a bunch of license
plates that show I think a great deal of
humility okay and I think we should
point these out for example check this
one out right here it says balding
license plate that says balding here's
this next one we saw on the freeway 26
calves well that could be braggy could
be right oh look at this one though this
one isn't look at this average height
it's on a Nissan now this one I thought
was very humble it just says psoriasis
there's no one checked this one out 4
inches hard
I do really wish I had gotten that other
play I do resort to a smaller shoot
embrace look at this one mr. GED here's
one I really liked yay food he this
one's very humble Zune in pepper here's
one IP 40 times a day and finally I saw
this one next to my car TBS sidekick
yeah I like to let people know
[Applause]